o Olá é um prazer essa noite tá Com
todos vocês e eu quero dividir um pouco
da minha história strangely Gonçalves Eu
tenho 49 anos o meu vida na o apelido
lindo que eu adquiri desde criança e que
no qual eu já conseguia desligar no meu
nome
Oi eu gostaria de dividir com vocês
algumas das experiências que eu já tive
em relação ao racismo e essa noite era
um tipo uma certa feita
e eu o procurava a indústria indústria
ele jantar Vai almoçavam um grupo de
diretores e um grupo de mensalista que
era o grupo que ele fazia parte alguns
alguma dessas pessoas comentado com ele
dignidade um restaurante badalado x
Aonde eles poderiam levar algumas
pessoas e conhecer também um lugar igual
chamaria muita atenção é porque ajudar a
encontrá-la
eu e o papai então ele sempre gosta de
dividir todos os sonhos Dele a minha Ele
nos põe uns levou um final de semana
para conhecer este lugar eu chegar lá
nós temos que pegar uma fila porque a
Zeni uma sequência Ela poderia entrar
nesse local e naquele momento o vários
velho pegou a chave do veículo quando o
carro só que uma das pessoas eu acredito
que seja um gerente ou diretor deste
local perguntou quem era aquele grupo de
pessoas que estavam lá
é isso aquele grupo qual era o carro
para aquele grupo estava e esse grupo
era minha família
a parte crer e direciona eles estão
Então vamos nomes dando sequência aquela
fila e entramos nesse restaurante
entramos esse local todos sem exceção os
olhos
Oi e ele passando ser observado em todos
os atos que aconteciam beber
e claro isso de uma certa forma um certo
constrangimento até porque qual era a
diferença nenhuma isso não ponto de
vista a família
O porém ele como criança tem que ter em
compreender porque eu não sabia que
aqueles olhares é pela nossa cor Ou se
era pelo uma classe social na qual nos
Estados ali e o de matar forma fiquem
também observando e sem obter Acaba Esse
entendimento vamos lá vamos e o meu pai
com seguinte observação Editora sem
perceber que todos nós somos observados
em 1
Oi e aí foi o primeiro contato que eu
tive com a Siri porque o que é o
seguinte a minha cabeça era por conta da
nossa sabia não
Ah e não foi só essa experiência que eu
tive adultas em
e inclusive nas referências que eu tive
dentro da minha casa dos meus pais
sempre deixaram muito claro que nós
temos e trabalhar estudar e ser alguém
acaba dentro da nossa vida profissional
a qual eram as oportunidades que naquele
momento surgiu eu fui ser empregado
doméstico que foi a primeira três
oportunidades que eu tive que eu abraço
do lixo
bom e foi trabalhar
bom e ali eu adquiri algumas
experiências Dentro de algumas
residências umas boas outras não com
tampas só tinha uma delas foi uma
oportunidade negativa que me marcou
muito uma dessas minhas patroas me
indicou para fazer uma faxina aí
residência residência era uma grande
estável as pessoas mais Eu sempre tive a
responsabilidade de urostomia cumprir
até o final quando eu cheguei lá vou
precisar à refeição eu fiquei agora na
minha vez de aguardar o nosso momento
é só que essa experiência é lá a pode
ser viu a todos dentro de casa ela pegou
o resto de toda a comida colocou em cima
da mesa dentro dessa desse resto havia
ali que fósforo e ela colocou o resto
suco de cada uma das pessoas daquela
casa
Um item ruim separar e jogou embaixo
tipo disse que era para eu me alimentar
daquela naquele momento o mais um
É porque eu queria ser tratar o ser
humano
e eu me levantei e disse travar Faça o
seu serviço e foi embora sair daquela
residência mas como indignação sim
dentro de mim porém a responsabilidade
de ajudar e coloquei dentro de mim que
haveria uma resposta social
a transformação EA partir dali voltei
estudar para que aquilo pudesse ser
transformado a mente e neste mesmo
período eu chamei na minha mãe que a
minha mãe tinha falado para minha mãe
vou voltar a estudar a minha mãe
resolveu através dessa palavra agradece
vendas indignação para estudar e às
vezes o motivo o supletivo na região com
segundo grau como concluir o segundo
grau se formos juntos uma para o e eu
sempre dizia para ela mãe eu tenho um
sono e eu vou organizar esse soro
profissional eu não sei que tem direito
que eu quero ser mas eu desejo ser
ligeiro
o iphon se signos signos caminhos
tentando só que nesse período da Vivo
abre outras outros desejos que fazer a
parte desse desejo é se casar ter filho
informar crescer profissionalmente entre
outras coisas natural do ser humano
Oi e aí dentro desse sonho
e eu acabei me casando primeiro antes da
realização profissional Sentir atração
só que aí no meio do caminho eu adquiri
uma depressão o meu casamento cai meu
casamento acabou infelizmente diante
disso a depressão sonhar acumulativa e
isso paralisou com Deus
já está sendo uma grande uma grande
tristeza e claro simplesmente Paulo só
que é
e eu descobri dentro de mim uma festa eu
não sabe o que que eu tinha
Oi e aí o meu filho me disse mãe eu
preciso de esse a cabeça junto uma
palavra que eu me levantei e retomei os
meus sonhos
eu voltei a trabalhar que isso já tinha
sido tirado da minha vida e eu conheci
um grupo no mês um grupo e me convidou
para consertar no Faro e eu fui se
panfletando farol porque eu me disse que
eu estava naquele período desempregado
e e e ali eu adquirir outras
experiências uma força que eu não sabia
que eu tinha eu descobri um
Oi sandriele uma dessas uma dessas Idas
e Vindas farol eu encontrei uma pessoa
que também fazia parte do meu círculo de
amigos
bom e quando eu estava ali fazendo meu
trabalho com Deus propriedades quando as
pessoas abrir o vidro na minha vó
e eu naquele mesmo momento eu sair da
onde estava esse veículo fui passar e
deu-me gozo
e não vai destruir o meu som
é mas sim tá construir e realizar aquilo
que já está dentro dias
o filme mente de seguir para o segundo
segundo a pessoa me disse que tem
vergonha de estar aqui
e eu respondi não porque eu teria
vergonha dentro de mim e me lembrei eu
posso colocar o braço amiga dentro de
casa aí desse veículo e continue o bom
trabalho
Oi e aí eu fiquei pensando
e quantos meus sonhos poderia ser
transformei aquela situação na que eu
gostaria que realmente acontecesse
e a esperança família EA transformação
daquilo que eu acredito
e nesse momento eu estava desempregado
conheci a coopercaps e fui trabalhar com
material reciclado mas como cooperada
último lote lá surgir outros sonhos e e
aqui dentro daquele sonho me fez
relembrar o que eu queria ser o Victor
nem presidente da coopertáxi cooperativa
de catadores de Mauá e laços de também a
oportunidade de concorrer uma bolsa
cinco anos originária ambiental
sanitária hoje qual é o meu sonho
realizado sim nem Presidente estou quase
me formando engenheira ambiental
solitário e foi escrito E você qual é o
seu sonho é